okay for people who are joining this
meeting we are live-streaming a meeting
about notebooks streaming ah and maybe
we should look at a demo and then what
we want to do is try and make the design
and UX of the whole thing so can we
start off with a demo of some kind
sure would you like me to create a
stream that you can connect to sure or
can i create a stream where do I have
this do I have a share if you still have
it doesn't look like you do here I'll
send the installation was a different
computer so I just put that in chat
a zoom chat letters
okay my god I missed were working 12.1
correct yeah she'd work okay so where is
that notebook streaming magnificent uh
[Music]
okay all right so let's look at this UX
who do we have here for for that
who is who is here to represent you X I
thought we were going to have UX people
here
sure yes about me here no she was the
one that added me to this meeting okay
who set up this meeting this is wrong
okay so why don't you get Jeremy Davis
okay we could ping Noah but it's
probably a bit too late for him and the
UK but you can ping him see if he wants
to join us we do that I'm still here
I'll let her know - okay and I don't
know where the Jeremy wants to bring in
somebody else to look at this design but
that's what we're gonna need that's what
this meeting was supposed to be about
what did we
this meeting was about anyway okay all
right so let's see the stream name you
entered is invalid okay well we should
we should take the actual UX of this
right so this is this is what we what we
presumably want is is in here where it
says new chat session right why don't we
get the people who designed the chat
stuff
go go go ask Andre who he wants to be
here okay okay so this has no stream
name other than the actual name here so
it has no stream title correct correct
which it probably optionally should have
yeah mate sounds reasonable
yeah okay so in the file new menu we
also want to can
- so it's almost an open isn't it I
suppose if you yeah yeah I suppose that
should there shouldn't be two separate
things yeah it's not really open right
it's new for either for the streamer or
the Streamy no but in the Streamy you're
going to open this up and suddenly a
window will pop up on your screen
yeah but new makes the window pop up on
your screen as well I mean if open is
very much finding an existing notebook
existing document alright okay so open a
file system viewer yeah okay so maybe we
can call this new streaming notebook
session notebooks notebook streaming
session didn't we once have some just
fooling around menus for this under the
file menu yeah I just had technical
issues with getting that to work
reliably is there's no way did we have a
file new and then streaming notebook and
that was also pop up that had two
choices oh yeah that was exactly exactly
this pop-up it was just instead of under
palettes notebook streaming it was filed
new streamed notebook sorry I I
previously had it under file new but I
just had technical issues with getting
that to work reliably
so there's file new and then streaming
notebook or something you know dot dot
dot and that seems yeah right below the
chat session item okay all right fine so
that's so then that becomes whoops it's
okay so taking it from the top that
would be file new oh gosh oh my gosh
this is really really broken Wow
this version is
absolutely host I can't do everything
about all the styling is all broken okay
great mr. Matt I can't I basically can't
use this as a yeah okay well this is
totally hosed okay let me let me not do
that then will this work in version 12
yes as long as you don't make a alpha
inline input box
okay do I have to reinstall the pikelet
and now I think it should still be there
since it's in the path Larry you're this
old version should auditory should
instantly recognize that it was
installed and there it is a nice feature
really a mat Todd I'm brilliant
congratulations in your brilliance
except that I'm not sure it was really
slow - okay so so um okay so this goes
wait a minute
what heck did you rebind keys or
something
it's not working here either all of my
all of my oh oh I know why it is it's
because you have the pop-up open now I
noticed that bug previously but I forgot
about it it's a front I'd presumably a
front-end bug but yeah if you just click
click the can't cancel
somebody needs to oh yeah that's
pretty serious problem it's effectively
a modal dialogue yeah it's a it's it's a
modeless dialogue whatever that means
but that's the window frame but yes like
in message dialog modal yeah I mean you
have to you use it and get rid of it
before you do anything else well yeah
except well it's inconsistent that you
can type underneath it but you can't
change the script okay so let's see if I
can type this here I mean I was looking
I got your dialog that okay
um do I have a place to store this well
you can store it in channel framework
it's IOD SW notes channel framework okay
all right so first
Oh's file new streaming notebook is that
correct yeah I think so or do we want to
have
or streamed notebook
I think streaming notebook is better um
and then
you
um okay
so let's do this again for some reason
this is very confusing to me if I say
new existing stream I mean that's a
Wolfram idea or what is that what is
that string it's lit literally the that
whole box is the channel name I mean I
really I didn't put too much thought
into the design of that but yeah it's
because when you when you create a
stream you can enter just a string
without the Wolfram ID because it will
by default create that well you it has
to create the channel under your your
wolf from ID and then when you view you
need to enter the needs you need to
prefix it with the Wolfram ID of the
person who's okay well fine so but that
means that when you type foo or
something it better complete because
otherwise you're not gonna know what to
tell anybody else to go to
what well what do you mean it should
complete what should complete um the
issue but when your notebook opens up at
the top it lists the full stream name
for users to connect to right yes it
does but I I certainly I wouldn't be
opposed to there just to just being a
you just enter a name and that becomes
universally unique that's how that's how
chat does it that would be perfectly
fine this was just easier so like you'd
enter foo and then you own you own foo
forever right
um okay well hold on so but you gotta
tell somebody else what this is right
and not everybody is going to have all
from IDs that look like that
and what do you mean by that not
everybody is going to have user at email
comm not everybody will have that that's
because because some of the
authentications for from IDs work
against single sign-on systems and all
kinds of complicated things okay so
there's no guarantee that it looks like
that okay I do know that but if you if
you go ahead and create a stream
notebook it'll show at the at the top
the full thing that people need to need
to enter can you clarify what you mean
by not not all Wolfram IDs will look
like that because I've I've never seen a
wolf right I know they don't exist yet
they will soon okay um okay let's
actually try running this
okay sorry
um okay sorry okay finally here all
right let's say testing so now what
happens if I that stream only lasts
during the time that I am currently
streaming right that their name is
recycled later or not now the name the
name is not recycled currently and
that's obviously not gonna work somehow
it can't be the case that forevermore
that's the only stream well I guess it's
like zoom sessions I mean I guess those
are those this missing missing element
though is that it's not currently the
case but what I plan to be the case
because I think it's probably the best
design is that the contents of the
stream are persistent at least for a
certain duration so if if every if
there's something if you create a stream
and then you do stuff in it then
everybody leaves you know look you know
what this is not a good idea what we
should do instead is the default should
be to create an anonymous stream
mm-hmm okay if you with a UUID right
yeah and then anybody who wants it then
you should say you should have a button
that says share stream with people and
you can send it by email you can send it
however you want okay and what if it's
what if it's like a presentation and
everyone's in the same room
what do you mean I mean if if you're
giving a president a presentation and
you want the people who are physically
in the room with you to connect to the
stream and be able to view stuff how
much to do that to our code and which
which you scan with what your laptop own
your laptop I guess I mean the I mean I
think that's if they can't reach the
people right so okay they could type
something in but they're gonna have to
type in something quite long and they
might get it wrong and the problem with
him typing it in is then you're saying
that you're gonna keep that stream
around you're gonna archive that stream
forever right okay yeah not necessarily
forever it can be defined time like I
don't know 30 days or something I mean
it's it's assumed that there's something
you've got to assume that it's it's
either I mean how are you are cutting it
it's just a cloud object no in the in
the database that will be backing this
thing the same because a database is
required to store cells so if someone
connects while the streams in progress
they can retrieve the current state of
the stream so we just we're gonna
archive it long-term we got a proxy it
through a cloud object or people will
never be able to get to it
okay well either I think there could
certainly be an option to to persist to
a cloud object but it can't be going
through the cloud object in real time
because that would just add add large
amounts of latency okay fair enough but
but then then when the stream has ended
okay most of these systems you know when
the stream has ended or you know after a
certain amount of time 45 minutes or
something often nothing has happened or
two hours or whatever it is then
actually just to archive itself okay yes
automatically I think so unless unless
you tell it don't archive the stream
okay I'm thinking more you will you said
when when the stream hands or just after
a certain amount of inactivity if it's
when the stream ends then that's that
the definition of that is when the
streamer closes their notebook so there
could just be there could be a pop-up
that says we don't like to save
now okay I don't think so well yeah
there could be I suppose just like a
notebook has a pop-up that says whether
you want to save it I mean but you could
save the streamer this streamer notebook
couldn't you directly to to the cloud or
- no no no - wherever it to wherever
it's been opened you could save it to
the desktop right yes and in principle
right now if you did that it has some
stuff attached to it that you wouldn't
want same dynamic things but I
presumably that I can presumably that
can be automatically removed so so yes
okay I just don't like the idea of
having another databases to maintain
well there has to be a database but I am
but it's a separate database it's just
their attempt at caching fun okay um but
look the options we need we clearly need
an option to record the stream right um
you know but we might want an option to
not record the stream sees this Amin
archive like say that yes yes that's
okay cuz record is for most people
that's the same okay
well record could also mean like
recording keystrokes but yes I yell you
mean well then maybe that's the wrong
thing but that's very confusing to say
archive this stream when you're just
starting it okay well is it keep an
archive with this stream okay I'm not
sure if presenting that when you first
started is is the best choice no it's
very confusing but but you but you know
if something crashes and you forgot to
check keep an archive of the scream
you're screwed right sure well if okay
but if
if we're trying to be able to save the
whole thing and in that in that case
that it needs to be then the the idea of
automatically saving every 45 minutes or
whatever that's not what I said I said
after 45 minutes of inactivity archives
itself and flushes itself from the
active database okay
then if it does crash then how does the
I mean I guess that's that's my problem
to solve but how does the server know
okay this is 45 minutes of inactivity it
archives if it checked keep an archive
of the stream it archives itself to the
to the cloud otherwise it just flushes
from the database and it's gone okay
fine don't you have to wait 45 minutes
if it does crash on you then don't you
have to wait 45 minutes so then be able
to go recover that that archived
notebook yeah that's what you want to do
yes okay yes I mean I think so
but but it should be if it crashes it's
still in the database right so you
should be able to reconnect to the
database okay sure yeah so within that
within that window yeah you're right
you're right did we get Brady in this
meeting we have Jeremy here no that's
not what I asked is Brady yeah
not yet how come
did you ask him I know you told Emma
tasks in my you told me to get Jeremy
and Noah okay
so dude I'm here let me go get him
okay
what's that oh that's your idea of how
people would would copy
unsure it's an idea in there just in the
upper left the close button
it's an amusing idea okay but so we got
to find the solution to how do people in
the room or remote get the stream name
well there are ways of generating unique
names that are not totally unreadable
untie pible like you you IDs are I agree
I agree so that seems like a reasonable
thing to do okay sure
like in in ECE we discussed this for the
URL shortener I think yes generate a
readable short name because because we
need we don't need more than you know
we've got ten million of these they'll
be fine
well and if they're recycled then yeah
well they won't be recycled in any times
yeah you just need to make sure that no
two of them well how would you access
the archive but from the name but well
from the name but it's been the archive
has been persistent to a cloud object
it's no longer in the database so it can
have that name but it's it's under your
your no you're out right so it has that
name so basically the archive name name
would be something like um streaming
notebook archive slash date whatever the
date is - the name yeah I'm not sure it
even really needs the name since if the
name is going to be audio generator
there's not much much use in using it
after it's no longer needed
like I think would just be the date fair
enough
fair enough but if you give it a name if
you if you have a a it could be the
title if there is one yeah okay if there
is a title that sounds good because I
think right now if you have been a chat
session if you don't give it a title
it's something like Jesse F's chat
session date okay fine then that's a
reasonable thing to do here
you
okay we had the wrong peep
this meeting unfortunately so this
meeting is not going to be as useful as
it could have been um it's really
unfortunate
okay in any case
all right so now I just start typing and
you could connect to the stream but for
some reason I'll show the stream name
okay I don't know why there's no Kolomna
oh I see coal on there okay
so you'd have to type in that whole
thing to connect to that stream right
yeah I just did it took me about five
seconds and I'm connected now you know
but you're a fast typist okay so if I
start typing here yeah I see it
okay all right so let me do it the other
way around you want me to make a stream
yup okay okay I just made one and put
the I put the name or whatever in the
same chat
okay turn
yeah that's not hooked up right right
now cuz I mean right now it's ambiguous
which one it should know to okay so here
obviously it should say the name of the
stream at the top shouldn't it or the
title if there's a title of the stream
yeah you're right it should okay so you
should be able to have here it should
ask for the title of the stream but I
think it should just give you back the
name of the stream because I don't think
any value to having something where
you're going to burn up well unless
unless we think that at any given time
right so what you're suggesting is if
you put in a name here that name will be
recycled because they will only it's
only relevant if you connect to that
stream after the stream is closed and
gone for 45 minutes for example then you
won't get anything but that's how that
stream could be reused later correct
correct
now do we have I'm not sure we've
established do we want people to be able
to choose a vanity name a custom name
for the stream or are we restricting
people to these auto-generated names I
think we should let them choose a vanity
name because it's going to come out with
their ID well I don't think it should
come out with their ID I don't think I
think I think we've got I think we're
we're beyond having me
having the L Wilson ID in there that's
fine so then they can pick a name and if
that name is being currently used in the
database it will it will lock them out
if it isn't being currently used then
they would never be able to connect to
that stream unless it was in this time
window so if they can guess the name of
a stream somebody is using then fine
they can connect to it but otherwise
they cannot write yeah okay and if they
don't enter a custom name it's an
auto-generated readable jourdonnais yes
yeah yeah but now is it archived under
that name though no apparently not it's
archived under the date unless they
created a name if they create a name for
it it should archive under that name and
then the date okay but what about the
title is we also had had that which
would be like what shows at the top it
should that be part of the archive name
I would think so yes if they give a
title I would say that's the thing if
they give a title then use that and the
date if they give a name I would say use
that on the date okay sure and if they
don't give a name just use the date or
use the okay what's between the title
and the name the honest what you type in
and the other is what it says at the top
of this notebook right although I don't
know why there's a difference really
yeah I mean typically people would use
the name make a name be the thing that
they want to appear yeah I kind of agree
why not just there there are there are
there would be some restrictions on on
the whatever we call it what's being
used as the unique identifier because
well one it has to be unique and then
two I mean probably it shouldn't have
spaces I mean laughter spaces files can
have spaces on them why can't it have
spaces it's gonna be used as URL at
canto spaces are we imagining that
somebody will go to this thing in the
cloud once we have this working in the
cloud they'll just go to a URL
presumably right yet I mean and even if
that's not a thing then even it still it
still could be in the archive name
because if they don't give it a title
but do give it a name name being the
unique ID that name cannot have spaces
in it otherwise I mean the URL looks
looks messy so it's I mean just in
general for short names it's it's it
makes makes a lot of things a lot easier
to say they don't get to have spaces in
fine we should give them a title and
that can override the name in terms of
what's Missouri seen sure now what
you've got here we don't want to display
that if this is displaying on you know
to a set of people we don't want to say
copy stream name it wants to be a
hamburger just like in presenter tools
or something
does it have to be the same can'tcan't
the user get something different than
the streamer the viewer no no this is
the viewer here oh right okay
but the point is the scenario is
somebody is giving a lecture and they
are showing their screen to everybody
okay people in the room also want to get
also want to see you know get streams of
what's going on yeah so I don't think
one wants to one could have the name of
the session of what they have to type in
here displayed um okay so the
at the top here could we display in that
notebook title something like um
streaming : and then whatever the
the URL is of the streaming thing
you actually mean the URL or the name or
title or whatever because having the URL
in that in that in that position isn't
very useful because you can't copy it
from there well you can type it in well
sure but I mean I'm not sure we've we've
really established what purpose the URL
has it all I mean it sounds like oh we
want the URL to be such that somebody
could just go to that URL and start
sitting seeing the stream okay any in a
cloud in a book in the browser well not
on a cloud notebook just in a browser
it should be a Wolfram cloud URL right
okay and then that would what would come
up there but what it would appear at
that URL something like a published
notebook just a notebook just like it
does in all cases okay so we'd say
let's see okay but but we also were
talking about okay so here we'll say
it'll say streaming okay so in a
streaming notebook it'll say at the top
I mean I don't think we need this bar
other than to just indicate that it's a
streaming notebook and we might want to
say stop streaming right toolbar with
with hamburger and otherwise it would
just be something if you don't open the
hamburger it would literally say
streaming
the the whatever you'd have to type in
to get it I would assume okay
is this is this in a toolbar or in the
the window bruh toolbar sorry okay then
what's in the window title
the title of the stream okay and if
there is no title the name and if there
is no custom neither the auto-generated
one okay that's all I would suggest yes
um
okay so this would be probably something
like this I mean we could generate a
short URL for it
okay do we want to automatically do that
for every stream notebook or making a
voluntary thing that we might as well
just do it oh you know or some fairly
short URL I don't know if we could say
well from cloud com
well I think Wolford RM is good it's
just I don't know if there is a I don't
know what the look the quota or capacity
of URLs it is I don't know if it's look
we can have something here just put
something on to that domain but I don't
know what it is it could be yeah it's
probably gonna be the unique name right
it's gonna be the unique name that
that's there um NS for notebooks
streaming you know stream slash okay
and then the unique name okay yeah
that's good cuz it gives us our own our
own namespace
you
why promote the web version of you know
above notebooks like a desktop notebook
we may be equal wait but that that
doesn't give you a way to open up a
desktop notebook yeah that's true
well we could gray down this part I
think that's confusing
yeah no one's gonna know what that means
well make it smaller or something I
don't know because because it is the
case you don't need to type that you'll
just type that unique name if you want
it on the desktop that's all you type is
that unique name see what I'm saying but
if you need it on the web it's that
other thing right so we maybe we just
list both well I'm trying to avoid
having a big pile of crud at the top of
this thing because people will see that
every time there you know that might be
you know somebody's grand televised talk
has this on it soon I'm saying right
well should it be a separate thing that
you pop up well no I think it's because
it should be there so people can see it
at the top of the screen I think this is
a reasonable solution and I think people
look if people don't only a people by
the time people know people know how to
get to a URL right if people have
desktop versions then the person says
this is the desktop you know type just
type the name right they'll figure that
out I think that's a reasonable solution
okay can we put something at the web
version that says you can also open this
on desktop this yes excellent I do I
expect idea that's a good idea
okay so now in the hamburger we
definitely want
you know show QR code we doesn't want
okay I'm not entirely convinced on how
useful QR codes are gonna be cuz okay
let's all tell you why it's useful I'll
tell you why it's useful sure
well I mean your point is why would they
by the time they can see the QR code
they can see it on their phone they can
see it at the screen so why do they want
to see it on their phone as well well
it's more than I think seeing it on
their phone is is like the reason that
this is the the value-add of notebook
streaming over just seeing it on the
screen is that you could copy cells and
play with them on your own I mean maybe
you can technically do that on mobile
but it's I totally object least stupid
to hold up um your computer to get a QR
code turn your laptop's around I mean
you need you need special software to be
able to scan a QR code on your laptop
like you can't do it in photos or
anything no I understand that but you
well I see you could use I see that by
that point yeah by that point it's all
toast okay well fine so that may not be
useful
okay but the problem is all right so
then in addition in the hamburger we got
to say send you know we got to have an
email thing send email and we've also
got to have stop stream and then we
gotta have a checkbox for keep an
archive of the stream keep an archive
back to the stream and so if so if it's
a checkbox then people can toggle that
back and forth as much as they want but
it only matters once the stream has
entered right whenever the state if it
is okay fine okay how does somebody know
how to get to the archive of this stream
so let's imagine that they're sitting in
the lecture that they want to get to the
archive of that stream after it ended
well off turret estimate yes well I mean
when the streamer closes it there can be
it there could be a pop-up that says
here's the archives but that's the only
thing I can think of well oh well that
URL that Wolford I know that doesn't
work because that's only valid while the
stream is running I thought that was
valid for like at least an hour some
time I understand that but well yeah but
if we it's well okay recycling
auto-generated unique names is probably
not an issue because there are gonna be
ten million or whatever of them possible
recycling vanity names is an issue
because at the moment we want to recycle
them as soon as they're no longer needed
but if we do that then that URL then no
longer means means anything and I think
that having oh that's a joke that then
suggests that we want to use the vanity
URL here because that way people will be
able to get to the archive afterwards
yes I think I think having having that
URL making that persistent or able to be
persistent is probably be in the long
run a good idea may be offended by
default persistent and you could just
destroy the archive if you don't want it
archived sure but I mean then it means
that the the vanity URL is also
persistent so that there's only one
forever
in level then we can't have a vanity URL
okay then we're just a locating a non
vanity URL for this for that but on this
okay so for everything it's just the
auto-generated short name I think so and
then it archives by default and then if
you go to that URL after the stream is
finished you will just get the archive
of that stream sure but okay saying that
that we can't have a sort of unique even
if it's not vanity we can't have a
long-lived name for you know my notebook
stream so people that people want to
join my notebook stream they have to get
a new name every time well there could
be could be this sort of similar to how
channel framework does it which I'm not
sure I think I'm is the right way but
how there is how you can have in the
global namespace just an auto-generated
name and then in the your wolfram ID
namespace any name you want yeah okay
that's I think that that's essentially
what we do for publishing right if I say
published a cloud right then I get
either specify name in which case it'll
be in that space there right or
automatically assign them a name in
which case it's to ID right well in this
particular case is a UID what we could
do a short right yeah yeah sure name so
I think that's probably the right
approach specify name in which case
it'll be part of your space right so it
can say Wolford am slash dreams that I
stole from slash blah whatever at that
point it's no longer a short URL right
no longer particularly short each saying
it's no longer particularly short yeah
but that name there is not your that
name is uniquely allocated right that
shortened name is uniquely allocated and
we have that
yeah
okay so we do want a QR code here
because you might want to flash that up
in the middle of the talk and say after
this talk is over go to this QR code and
you'll get that and you can go look at
the the archive and if you want to get
it on your phone while it's running then
go there otherwise you can just leave
that thing on your phone and when it's
over it'll go to the archive of the
thing okay sure yeah by the way just for
people on the livestream you absolutely
have barcode recognized which reads QR
codes yes that now will let you hold up
your laptop to to scan the QR code yes
okay okay so then okay on the viewing
side the title if there is one then
Streamy notebook
um I think the Streamy would technically
be the notebook being streamed not the
person receiving it
you
okay and in on receipt on the receiver
side yeah
um then what you would have at the top
is um viewing stream bla bla bla bla bla
I assume you just say that wouldn't you
yeah title or if there's no one the
short URL that cascade of things yeah
right but I mean I think you need a
stripe that says you're in you have a
streaming notebook here yeah I agree but
what's the title of the whole notebook
well the The Tyee title could be viewing
stream : that thing and then the bar
could just be something like I don't
think the title should be a viewing
anything I think the title should be
whatever the title that's given to the
stream is okay well that I was just
suggesting that with a viewing stream
prepended but yes it could just be the
title okay
and then maybe the toolbar just says
viewing stream I don't know what options
it would have would it have options well
maybe a link to the archive or what will
be here yeah okay all right so then it
can have then over on the writer can
have a link to URL or something yeah I
mean it's not I'm not sure there's what
a good way of describing what that URL
is is well why don't we give them a
hamburger and then they can look and see
that it'll say archive URL okay that I
mean exponent would Hermann on URL yeah
permalink in which case it could just be
a permalink icon over on the right is
there an icon for that yeah there is a
standard icon for that okay okay so then
if you
try to type here it just doesn't type a
simile it should be and go away and
things like that how are you doing that
how are you doing the lack of typing is
it an editable false deletable false
okay fine
now
you
I mean we could set these things to be
clicked to copy
well I mean it's just it's just you can
just copy the cell bracket
no I understand that you didn't copy but
I mean given that the only action you're
gonna want to do is copying oh whatever
you might want to sub get a sub piece
now
can you send me a graphic please sure
thank you cemetery on the village also
okay so on my side I can independently
so this is like a published notebook on
my site I can definitely resize it yes
now the reason the fact that that works
is a little bit serendipitous and now I
think if I go and try to resize this it
might go through T yeah so it it's you
can you can do that but that's only
because Anna table falls doesn't catch
that kind of thing it's still gonna try
to as it is now it's still gonna try to
sink my my state with your cousin I
think that's excellent behavior I like
that very much
I think people might well want to okay
so now send them an appeal it right now
that's same same scenario here so you
should be able to drag that I think but
then if you I should then be able to
take over this is great this is very
easy to understand this is just like a
published notebook okay oh you're on it
this is great that I can I can open and
close cell brackets so that what you're
doing is you're having a
incrementally built published notebook
basically you need wait what does happen
with a closed cell bracket like reverse
closed the circle and Jesse you edit the
code what happens no idea but here I
just collapsed and then hung collapsed
collapse again and collapse yeah that
doesn't surprise me but is weird right
that the when I didn't see what happened
I was it stayed collapsed I don't even
know if it made changes okay cuz that's
that's like a property of the cell group
data or something right yeah yeah it's
only the cell objects themselves that
are getting synced
but what if Stephen collapses that cell
with no with the graphics the input
showing and then you edit it
you reevaluate it or something I suspect
that it will sync and then when he
uncollapse is it that'll show so Stephen
can you collapse
I guess what regular with the novel in
this way normally other one wouldn't
what should i do like make it read or
something I change the graphic okay oh
it already opened it already open we'd
open again
okay someone's asking how much network
bandwidth will this use not very much
right you're just sending diffs aren't
you well not actually dears it's sending
the whole cell every time but only the
cell that's been edited so it could be
up to like if you make some giant image
like a couple megabytes and a Canon that
in the setup of this meeting which was
just completely insane we don't have the
cloud people here right now so because
they have their own collaborative
editing mechanism at a cell level which
this should plug into I think but I
think we at least understand okay so
let's assume so we understand the what
am I saying we understand the the basic
structure here um hi do we
and how difficult this project is just
designed sure I think the basic
functionality without the cloud cloud
viewability and potentially without
archiving is fairly simple like a month
of development maybe it's not sample
that's nice simple at all ok fine I'll
simple okay simple is relative but yeah
like a month of development that that's
my estimation at least I have no idea
how how difficult the cloud stuff is so
yeah well we've got to find that out so
let's bring this up then in the next
cloud development meeting let's we'll
probably need a presentation of this
it's kind of a mess up okay um the next
cloud you mean your the meeting with you
Steven yeah I mean unless you thought
maybe you can talk to you can ask yarn
pull him into this and ask him um I'll
bring it up in the cloud group
development meeting tomorrow
um okay all right sounds good
anything else for right now here well
Jesse I just wanna make sure you are you
clear on the notes this team has put
together for the UI you understand all
of the decisions that were made it's one
of these yeah that makes sense I guess
just one thing to check is are there
still two buttons in that in that
dialogue like what does what does the
dialogue what should the dialogue look
like the create history well I think we
should have two separate honestly I
think
there's such different actions really I
mean the type of person who's going to
be creating one of these is it's not
really quite the same action um most
people who connect to one of these I
think that the default should be connect
to a stream and there should be a button
on there that says create a new stream
and it should take you to a different
thing because you're gonna have to pick
your name and title and god knows what
else right so I think file new um in
which case it really isn't a file new
it's more like an open I think it's like
you know it should we file streaming
notebook and then um well the precedent
is chat session which is which is a
similar sort of thing you can connect to
an existing chat and that is under file
new no it doesn't oh it is under file
new well I understand that I don't think
it's right because I think what we
should do here is default to connecting
to an existing thing and then have a
button that says create a new stream
okay but it's gotta be under file new
not file opened well fair enough we
don't have a submenu for file open
anyway okay found you okay maybe we
should just say notebooks stream dot dot
dot
so it isn't streaming notebook it's
notebook stream if you say file new
notebook stream um I I don't know what a
good name is but if I saw file new
notebook stream I wouldn't have those
heinous idea what that was not that it
really matters because I tried once and
then I might figure it out but I mean
one is I do know police better I think
so because at least I understand it's a
notebook
well stream sounds like some weird
connections or some I don't know what it
sounds like
well file new EX notebook is evokes the
the imagery of creating a Denby file
which this under the hood is but at the
top level looks something different so I
think file new notebook stream that's
what I'm leaning towards at least there
is no way I'm gonna be able to do the
next meeting that I was supposed to do
here
hopeless um no should have said it
earlier in the day oh sorry
okay um yeah okay there's people on the
live stream is suggesting other things
like a live notebook
I think live notebook unfortunately
reads this live notebook um notebooks
silver isn't quite right because that's
a yes a different thing well anyway I
think this told to be figured out here
sure okay and then just one other thing
to continue to consider can people
stream an existing notebook convert it
into a stream or something because right
now you can copy cells you can pay cells
into your streams notebook you can't
convert an existing what a taking an
existing notebook and making it into a
notebook stream or a streamed notebook
or whatever pushing it live so to speak
that will be cool if you could do that
though and then it would just and then
and then everybody it would show up what
you have already would show up and then
everything you now type would then show
up right um so I guess just what the
what the UI is for that and then like
does it mean since making a well that's
a good reason
to have a more complicated UI for create
notebooks stream because then it can say
it can say use an existing notebook or
start a new notebook okay yeah I think
that that's good and then if you use an
existing notebook would it be okay to
essentially duplicate it and the
duplicate becomes the stream because I'm
not sure if you if it's converting in
place it's crazy to convert em okay
start from existing notebooks I think
the the the create new notebook or start
from existing notebook content
you
something like that
start numerable for us to start from
existing upward content
okay and seeing that screenshot below
makes me think or do we care about
permissions having anything less than
public
do we have any way to do that uh well I
mean we don't really have anything yet
but I mean it's it's certainly possible
it's just I I can imagine that the the
UX would be more more difficult because
people might not be logged in as an
account that's been granted permissions
I think the the use cases for this that
have been come up with like like a
lecture or a or like an online class or
something um don't permissions well
actually the other thing is somebody
might want to know who is watching my
stream that's that's definitely doable
that's easy it's that easy because if
you don't if they're not authenticated
users how do you know okay well if
they're not authenticated users then
well no we don't know but just seeing
what what is listening on that on the
channel isn't like an existing
capability but I don't know what what to
do if they're not authenticated users I
mean it could just say for anonymous
users yeah sure well I think there may
be a reason to have permissions but I
don't know if we're gonna have
permissions they've got to be proxied
through the the only way I can imagine
that working is to somehow proxy them
through cloud objects well channels
already have permissions and those are
handled entirely on the on the server
they don't support certain things like
like permissions groups because there's
there's that's very very difficult to
keep what's on the server and sync with
what's in the cloud but they do support
like I mean obviously they do support
for granting permissions to just Wolfram
ID saying you can write you can read and
simple thank you feels really simple and
nothing buried under all sorts of
features well for that published
published notebook has just allow anyone
to access and password protect so
password protect not too much longer
that's gonna go really okay there's an
advanced tab that's coming which is
vastly more elaborate okay nevermind
then um look I think you can assume it's
public for now
okay okay you can assume this is part of
our publishing story not part of some
permission sharing story okay sure
um well it looks good okay you need to
talk to the cloud people before we green
like this and figure out you know so we
figure out how that's going to work
there
even if yeah and they may have some very
easy way to do it
if we're lucky they will okay using some
fancy react thingy weather just
basically yeah I can imagine it being
quite easy I can also imagine it being
quite hard so let's find out um great
how is their qtt channel broker thing
going good very very nearing nearing
completion the code is basically done
it's just the architecture stopped which
I'm gonna be getting all right um okay
well sounds good all right we should I
wrap this up thank you to folks on the
livestream it's a could have been a more
perfect meeting if we'd had the right
people here from the beginning but so it
goes this is good functionality it's
very nice Jessie um alright
Tokyo soon alright bye bye